[Music]
[Applause]
so the PlayStation 4 lots of good stuff
coming out on it we had exclusives like
infamous and non exclusives that were
also awesome but it's kind of hard to
pick from a category that has such great
games on it right I mean you played
transistor a lot you loved transistor
there were some fantastic nominees this
year but for me and for everyone else
Middle Earth shadow Mordor and it was
just for me it was my best experience on
PlayStation 4 what do you think it's
like a next-gen game like we have the
PlayStation 4 in the Xbox one it is
their generation so we want to see like
new stuff you want to see developers
part of you grounded taking big risks
and that Nemesis system was a huge risk
that thing could have not worked at all
but they pulled it off and it's so
intricate you go in and you you know
from start to finish all of these
enemies that you come up against have
their own abilities and their own
weaknesses and their own personalities
and they interact with you in different
ways and sometimes they come back after
you hurt them and they have this
vendetta against you and I think that
that deep of a rabbit hole it's so hard
to look at any other game that has a
system where you're constantly fighting
it helps you craft a story like yeah
they have a story in that game but it's
essentially your story there are these
orcs there are these personalities that
you see and they you develop these
vendetta's and you don't know where
they're gonna show up they might be
dogging you they might just like come in
in the middle of a fight that you're
already kind of overwhelmed and like not
this guy again the way that that is
almost like procedural personality gives
this game and that is just such an
incredible innovation no it's been a
time when you think about it like the
traditional third-person action game
they're basically bred calm friends who
are like going to this place doing the
mission do it hitting the boss doing the
mission hitting the buster
like it's only after about five or six
hours of mordor you're like wow I'm
actually playing this third-person
action game in a way that I've never
been played an action game or at least
not that often and then you know we can
rattle on about the Nemesis system and
cited us it's a really solid game like I
really enjoy the combat I really enjoy
the exploration I think one thing we all
seem to agree on is the Nemesis system
is the one mechanic in 2014 that's most
likely to impact games that is a
next-gen system
shadow of Mordor is the first game that
has come out this year that I feel
next-gen game and it's funny you say
that because of course the previous gen
versions of this game did not have the
NamUs he asked them so they're
completely right